I forgive ends of the Nerds movie you've
never seen that movie oh yeah a great
movie yeah because of that I [ __ ] up
putting a condom on for the first time
yeah do you remember when they you
really got to know this movie i watch
this movie a lot but they walk the two
nerds in the Alfa's to the Alpha omegas
and they see two sheep there and they go
gentlemen and they go like this with
condoms and they roll out they like I
had I'm unrolled and they just went
blink and I went oh so the first time I
put on a condom
I go you gotta roll it like Revenge of
the Nerds or the way my mom rolls my
socks up she was all rolled up
so I unrolled it thinking that's how you
throw in a condom I never put on them
before I'm 17 years old
ice co2 slide it on when I push it over
air is trapped in the side of it and as
I push it just inflates uh-huh and I'm
like trying to squeeze the air out of it
like I'm making balloon animal and so I
[ __ ] ruin that condom there's a first
time promo who's the girl yeah I know of
course I remember yeah do you hear
dating or was it a one night's dating
dating so I go out to Jeff Hartley he's
in the living room or watching Pet
Sematary he's with his bro we had two
condoms we got a member 16 17 years old
we got him into exile on the corner dale
mabry and Erlich so I go over shot the
exon so I go over I go hey man I need
that I need that other condom and he's
like you already did it and I go it's a
long story to him and he was like all
right so I grab it and then words like
reservoir into the reservoir tip make
sense to me I know yeah
roll it over even putting it off felt
good I was like whoo
I thought I always felt weird oh-hoh was
the first kind of my better put all in
my life other than the one where I made
the balloon animals so then I get on top
of a real-time one done that's right
done one pump one pump that's a night
done Wow doggy
of course called me so a horny man hey
you premature ejaculation now Oh bro I
did all through my 20s one table was she
like
what she looked at me dead serious looks
at look on my face and goes are you
gonna put it in and mr. vagina I [ __ ]
between her butt cheek in the bed and
came
[ __ ] [ __ ] a man I knew came and
then I had the [ __ ] deal with a
compromised atomic it to put the copper
here's like going on a hike going hey
why don't you get those dry socks and
shoes jump in the river real quick we'll
go from dicks barely well at that age
you're good to go
my first time you never [ __ ] with a
condom let me I mean I'm never like Jack
you were never on a big condom where I
were you still not there for [ __ ] so
come on what are we doing syphilis bring
it in my even think if I had my first
gay experience I'd be like bro you're
putting on a condom I do kind of [ __ ]
movie that raw dog me yes dude Rob do
you like that I'm getting [ __ ] in this
game just rolled on Bolivia's I was like
we're all dog me bro
I want to be infected that was
impressive that was impressive but would
your attack the condom I couldn't feel
anything so I lasted forever
ah and it was it was so uncomfortable
she was dry it was a nightmare
Oh nightmare no not not a good
experience now nightmares and there's
dad walked in on us oh no really
and he was drunks I didn't realize what
was going on
he's like a denier ball alright you guys
tired you can close the door I'm like
tired I'm balls deep and your daughter
here sir [ __ ] what would you do that's
we'd say you guys must be tired she went
quietly I got stiff then he left she was
like oh my god I'm like anyway was not
very romantic was not very porno ish it
was awful
dry right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]